hello youtube chess lovers and my
friends this is gunjan over here
and last weekend i have played a game on
chess cube which was really interesting
and i thought i should share with you
guys
i was playing as a black and my opponent
was really high rated it was around 2000
plus and at the time i was written
around 1850
and here it's right to move
but before going into all of this uh
let's analyze the situation
black is materially up or one pawn up
and
white has an initiative because it's
white whites to move
uh
most of the scenario like this i call
them as a confusion scenario the reason
behind this like let's say both side the
kings are open
and any side who made a tactical blunder
or
couldn't continue well can end up easily
with the losing side
so
you require lots of calculations lots of
sometimes sacrifices as well
and
because i was playing a time time like
let's say 15 minutes game so
it was restricted by time as well so we
have to consider all of these factors
and
after the 50s 57th move of the game we
reached to this position and we both
have approximately seven minutes left in
our clocks
and
at this point my opponent probably think
around two and two and a half minutes
and
he come up with a
clinical move orders which really ripped
me apart
and
i let let me flip the view so
now you are watching from the white
perspective
and just pause the video over here and
try to finally find it out a clinical
way to you know defeat the black
okay welcome back
uh
some of you have like you know
think that first move the white will be
moving this king over here
and it's logical as well because
let's say if the black couldn't identify
the thread and let's say if he plays any
random moves like this
then it will make the checkmate
so that's a good idea but
the problem with this idea is
black has a really nice move in his
sleeve
which is moving this rook over here
and now
the problems are swinging over to the
right side because
let's say if the
fight really play a casual move like
let's say moving rock over here
then black can checkmate the white
so
king to
a6 is
it's a good option but it's not a
clinical way to finish the black
so what are the other possibilities
well ideally the way my opponent played
it was really awesome and i checked with
the engine later and engine come out
with the same
waters so
without wasting a time let's go straight
to that model
just think what will the first move the
white
okay the first move the white is a
border verse is giving the check to the
black king
and here black
has to go to the b8 square
notice that if the king go to the b
sorry a7 square then white has a really
checkmate in two which is
giving a check by the rook and when the
king over here this is checkmate
so here
black has to go to the b8 square
and now guess
what will be the second move of the
white
uh
second move the white i think many of
you have already guesses because this
rook is already hanging with the screen
so you have to do something with this
rope so of course it's giving a check to
the black king
and here
black has three options
first is
this one
second is going this side and the third
option is taking this rope
if
first option is obviously the bad one
because if the king go over here this is
checkmate
so king can't go over there
and let's take the second option which
is king mu over here
well here
white has a checkmate in six six so
if you want to try that you can pause
the video i'm going for it right now so
queen check the king wing over here
then there's a knight jack
and let's say king mo over here then
again the queen chad
if the rook coming between this is
checkmate
so
that's not possible and if the king
moving over here
this is a
deadly check by the knight and
the reason behind is it's not only
forking the king and a queen
but black king doesn't have any place to
hide so forcefully black has to take
this knight and this is checkmate
so that it's all about the second option
and
let's go to the third option we're here
oh sorry
uh
yep here
third option which border was black has
to go into that because other two
options are really bad for them for him
so
black will take this brook
and now
uh now come the really interesting part
now can you find the third clinical
move of the white
okay
it is really strange but
moving the king over here
and seriously even i didn't expect
expect from my opponent i thought he
might will take with the knight or it
has some technique with the
a8 square with the queen
but this really surprised me
and
the reason behind this is a clinical
move is now black
have only one one move to defense defend
that you know b7 square because white is
threatening a checkmate over there
so only move black has is the moving
group over here
and now can you guess
the next clinical move of the white
which is a really really good one
and
and that is
twin check from the a8 square
and
after this
when i was just for a second when i was
looking at the board i said oh my god
like i have three pieces where white has
only night
but here the magic starts
and let's say first white knight will
take this
bishop and there's a check
and unfortunately king has only one
square to go which is b8
where here the knight will take again
with the check and look at the beauty of
the chess
although
black was just
two moves ago three pieces
the two major pieces up
now
it's
uh like let's say two pawn versus a pawn
and a knight with the white
so what a beautiful sequence
and no matter
what your class is this is a really easy
win for the white
so here there are two options let's say
in first option which i did like chasing
that knight and trying to
queen that
pawn on the
uh f file
because pawn on the a file of the black
is will be dying soon so there is no
point of staying there
so
let's say let's say
going into the first option king will
chase the night so
here it will uh it happens in the game
i my opponent took that pawn and i
attack on the night and then he
it it was a really great idea by him
what he was trying to do is like
he was any point where knight can take
that pawn
he he he will do it
and
if if the black is not like let's say if
the king is keeps using the knight the
ma light will move around here and there
and it will waste the time of the black
and the mean time the white pawn will go
up
so that was a really simple strategy
and
i had i have no options to
deal with that so
for few other few more i was keep
dancing like this and then
here i resign because
it's even a beginner can win from here
so that was the first option let's say
second option
you can
like let's say here
you can forget about that pawn you can
try to do let's say
king on the a and the b file so
the other other way it can be goal is
like this
and king is trying to stay on this side
but even though that will not help
because let's say after this
if we don't have a knight here it will
be still made
or maybe
sorry not the statement but black can
win over here
but uh the difference is here is we have
night and the simple way is like we can
retrieve the knight here
and now blacking has to go over here and
this is an easy queen and then this is a
really easy win for the wide
so
this was a really awesome game and
i found it really interesting because
the move that the knight which captured
the whole
three pieces was really beautiful so i
thought i should share with you guys
well thank you for watching my video and
i'll post a new video soon
see you bye